moi je vais vous présenter on va dire 4
4 éléments qu'on peut qualifier
d'artillerie primitive veut glaire
serpentine bombarde
voici quelques-unes des pièces
d'artillerie à poudre que l'on peut
découvrir au château de chinon
ces pièces sont authentiques elle date
du 15ème siècle
elle raconte l'histoire de la mise au
point de ce qu'on appelle communément
les bouches à feu n'ont en fait se
répand au milieu des 14e et jusque aux
années 360 480
ce sont des canaux qui tire simplement
d'aider des projectiles de plomb est pas
beaucoup de force ou des sortes de
grosses flèches mais au xvème siècle
les armes vont devenir de plus en plus
efficaces les maître canonnier forgeron
que certains princes s'arrache pour
affiner leur technique et elle reste
complexe car ces canons sont de
véritables mécano l'eau refus sont
constitués d'une multitude de pièces en
fer et finaliser avec une série
d'anneaux soudé liaisonner à chaud et
français et les bourguignons avaient
développé dans la partie d année 460 110
et ce canon et un peu le début de cette
ligne est une approche nouvelle
consistant à ne plus chercher à faire de
très grosses pièces des bombardes géante
mais plutôt à faire des canons plus
petit mais plus puissant capable de
projeter des boulets de faire car le but
est de percer les murs eyes et demi avec
cette bombarde
on atteint une plus grande puissance de
feu
on en voit très peu aussi avec ses
architectures de bois destinés à
protéger les hommes et les machines
qu'on a reconstitué ici et qui s'appelle
des affûts ou des trains de roulement en
général au mieux quand on va les
apercevoir dans des châteaux elles vont
être délaissés peut être présenté dans
un coin mais généralement les fora pas
été fait de faire la reconstitution de
ces pièces de charpenterie pour les
mettre en situation et ces armes ont été
décisives
c'est par exemple grâce à cette
artillerie à poudre que les troupes
françaises remporteront la bataille de
castillon en 453 elle permis la fin de
la guerre de cent ans qui oppose à la
france au royaume d'angleterre